اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا المساء
لماذا اخترع بايدنا تعجل في الاعلان عن
ترشحه لرئاسه على غير عادته وهل هناك ضغوط
سياسيه او انتخابيه دفعه الى ذلك
هل هي واقعيه وقابله
وما هي الياتها وهل يمكن ان تقبلها واشنطن
ومنورات الصين هل هدفها تطويق تايوان
والضغط عليها فقط ام ان ساعه الصفر اقتربت
لي غزو الجزيره
ونحييكم الى تفاصيل الملف الاول اعلن رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن عزمه الترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسه لعام 2024 واضاف خلال مقابله على
شبكه ام بي سي انه ليس مستعدا بعد للاعلان
عن ذلك رسميا فيما كشفت مصادر ديمقراطيه
مطلعه لشبكه
ان بايدن لم يستقر على مدير حملته ولم يتم
اختياره المقر الرئيسي سواء فيلادلفيا او
والمينكتون وعبر كريس كونز سيناتور
الديمقراطي في دلاوير وحليف بيضا المقرب
عن اعتقاده بان احتماليه عدمت وعدم ترشح
بايدن غير وارده واضاف كونز حينها ان
بايدن سيعلن ترشحه للرئاسه وفقا لجدوله
الزمني فيما نقلت العربيه نات ان سبب
الجوهري لتاجيل بايدن اعلنت ترشح لرئاسه
ارتبط بالامور الحاكمه مثل رفع سقف الديون
وتجنب الانشرار الى الصراع السياسي
[موسيقى]
للفوز بانتخابات 2024 جو بايدن يبحث عن
وسائل جديده للوصول الى الناخبين والحل
الامثل وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
البيت الابيض سيعتمد على مئات المؤثرين
على المنصات الاجتماعيه للترويج لسجله
وسيتم توفير غرفه احاطه خاصه بهم
الخطوه تهدف الى تعزيز مكانه بايدن بين
الناخبين خاصه الشباب والتوجه نحو الذين
قد لا يتابعون البيت الابيض او الحزب
الديمقراطي على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
خطوه البيت الابيض علامه على ان غرفه
الاحاطه الصحفيه التقليديه لم تعد مركز
الرسائل الوحيد للاداره الامريكيه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من اورلاندو
عبر سكايب توم حرب رئيس وتحالف الامريكيه
الشرق الاوسط للديمقراطيه اهلا بك ومن
هيوستون عبر سكايب احمد الحنطي الباحث في
الشان الامريكي اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
اسمحوا لي ان ابدا معك استاذ احمد في
الواقع في سؤالنا الرئيس لهذا الملف طرحنا
فكره او سالنا لماذا استعجل الاعلان
وحضرتك تعلم بان بايدن ليست بالمره الاولى
التي يتحدث فيها عن نيته ترشحه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه البعض الاخر في المقابل بان يقول
بانه لم يستعجل ابدا بالعكس او هذا كذلك
مقاله في تصريحاته في اخر 2022 قال باني
لن استعجل الاعلان واني انتظر ان تكتمل
الصوره وتكتمل التحضيرات لماذا في كل مره
بايدن يعلن ولكن ليس رسميا نيته الترشح او
عزمه الترشح للانتخابات ما تفسير ذلك
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
بطبيعه الحال الاشكاليه في الاعلان رسميا
يعني عندما يعلن المرشح رسميا ترشحه
للانتخابات هناك قوانين خاصه يعني تفرض
حدود معينه على طريقه وعلى حجم التبرعات
التي يمكن له جمعها بالتالي بايدن لا يريد
ان يدخل تحت هذا التعريف حتى اخر لحظه
ولكن الاشكاليه التي يواجهها ان هناك من
يتشكك في قدرته على الترشح بحكم سنه
فبالتالي هم يطالبونه يعني اذا لم تكن
تريد ان تترشح فعلا فان لديك يعني عليك
واجب تجاه الحزب بابلاغه مبكرا لكي تبدا
يعني عمليه اختيار الخليفه من سياتي بعده
لذلك هو يؤكد دائما انه سيترشح ولكنه لا
يعلنها رسميا ولكن لماذا لم يتفق على ذلك
من قبل يعني سيد توم هناك من يقول بان
هناك قرار قد اتخذ من مستشار بعيدا وهذا
ما نقلته كذلك ام بي سي حضرتك تعلم بان
بايدن كان حاضر مع زوجته بمناسبه عيد
الفصح ومن هنا اتت تصريحات عند حضوره في
تودايشو
وام بي سي استكملت بحثا في هذا الموضوع
اتصلت ببعض المسؤولين قالوا لها بان
القرار قد اتخذ ولكن بايدن منزعج من الضغط
الحاصل عليه من اعلان رسمي لذلك فلم نفهم
لماذا هذا الضغط لماذا هذا الانزعاج ما
الذي يحدث بالتحديد في دائره بايدن
ضغوطات
للمرشحين غير الرئيس
بايدن ربما لجمع الاموال قبل الحمله
الانتخابيه فاذا تاخروا وتاخر الرئيس
باعلان ترشحه كمان
يتاخرون وعلى المثال حاكم ولايه
كاليفورنيا يحاول الترشح عبر عن رايها عده
مرات وقام بعده زيارات لعده ولايات
السيناتر عن واسترجينيا
عبر عن رايه بانه من الممكن ان يترشح فاذا
فهذه الضغوطات ضمن الحزب الجمهوري ضد
الحزب الديمقراطي اليوم على الرئيس بايدن
ليعلن موقفه فاذا هو الذي سينافسوه
بالانتخابات التمهيديه القادمه ام
سينافسون مجموعه اخرى ليحددوا اهدافهم
السياسيه ومن هذا المنظار عليه ان يعلن
ترشيحه اليوم قبل هو يفضل ان ينتظر حتى
حتى ربما اوائل السنه القادمه وهذا ربما
سيكون متاخرا اذا انتظر لذلك الفتره احمد
هل نفهم مع كل هذه الاشارات بان هناك تخبط
داخل الحزب الديمقراطي
لا اعتقد انه تخبط بقدر ما هو تخوفه البعض
يخشى ان لا ينوي الترشح ولكنه يؤجل هذا
الاعلان لكي لا تتاثر اجندته التشريعيه
والتنفيذيه لانه عندما يصبح الرئيس في
نهايه فترته الاخيره فان تعامل الكونغرس
معه يختلف عن عندما يكون امامه يعني فتره
ممتده احتمال اربع سنوات جديده
وفيغشل بعض ان بايدن لا ينوي الترشح ولكنه
لا يريد ان يقول حتى اخر لحظه حتى لا يؤثر
على اجدته ويحاولون الضغط انه هذا سيضر
بالحزب وان لديك مسؤوليه تجاه الحزب اذا
لم تكن تترشح فيجب ان تعلن اباك مهما كان
الثمن بايدن لا يريد ذلك لانه كما ذكرنا
لا يريد ان تفرض عليه الشروط والحقيقه انه
عندما يكون الرئيس ينوي اعاده الترشح
مجددا فان هذا الوقت يعني منتصف العام قبل
الانتخابات اكثر من سنه ونصف يعتبر وقت
مبكر جدا للاعلام ولكن تعتقد فعليا بان
بايدن لا ينوي والترشح سيتم هل توافق ضيف
ي في ذلك وان كان نعم لماذا كل هذه
التصريحات المتتاليه فهمنا بان هناك
حسابات داخل حسب الديمقراطي ولكن كان
بالامكان ان لا يطرح مثل هكذا افكار مرارا
وتكرارا في عدد مناسبات
لان الرئيس بايدن يعرف وخاصه هو له اكثر
من خمسين سنه بالعمل السياسي بانه الناخب
الامريكاني يصوت باول اول شيء بهم ياخذ
الامريكاني هو الوضع الاقتصادي وهذا فشل
فيه الرئيس بايدن والتضخم المالي اليوم
هائل بالولايات المتحده النقطه الثانيه هي
الوضع الاجتماعي ونحن نعرف ان الحدود
مفتوحه في على المكسيك وهنالك تخبط بالوضع
الاجتماعي الداخلي وثالث نقطه هو على
الوضع الخارجي ونعرف بانه الكوارث الذي
يرتكبها الرئيس بايدن من الانسحاب من
افغانستان والحرب باوكرانيا والوضع
بتايوان فهذه المشاكل الثلاثه هو يفضل ان
يؤخر الاعلان عنها لما بدء يبداون
الديمقراطيون بمحاسبته على هذه النقاط في
الانتخابات
ترى بانه يؤخر الترشح ولكن في النهايه هو
سيعلن ترشحه ورسمه وربما يجب ان يفعل ذلك
في حين الاستاذه احمد يقرا بانه لن يترشح
في الحالتين وكان هناك تذبذب في قراره او
داخل الحزب الديمقراطي والبعث ربط هذا
التذبذب بقرار ترامب البعض يقول بان بايدن
قد يكون الشخصيه الامثل لمواجهه ترامب ما
رايك في هكذا فراغي سيد احمد هل لترامب
علاقه مع هذه التصريحات
انا اريد ان اصحح نقطه انا لم اقل ان
بايدن لا يترشح قلت ان هناك بعض من في
داخل الحزب الديمقراطيه يخشون من ذلك
ولكنه اذا ذكرت في اكثر من مناسبه حتى
يعني من خلال بانوراما ان الترشح بايدن
مساله محسومه بايدنت سيترشح ما لم يتعرض
لعرض صحي خطير ومفاجئ
طيب مفهوم هذه النقطه علاقه ترامب بهذه
التصريحات هل تقرا او هل تعتقد بان
لتصريحات ترامب كذلك ونيته الترشح علاقه
بظهور بعيدا وحديث عن عزمه الترشح هو كذلك
لا اعتقد ذلك
يعني الدوائر المحيطه به تلمح باستمرار
انها تفضل ترامب كمرشح منافس من الحزب
الجمهوري ولكن لا اعتقد ان الاعلان ترامب
اي علاقه مباشره بخطط بايدن لانه لو كان
له علاقه مباشره لربما اعلم باكرا بمجرد
اعلان ترامب للترشح
سيتم كيف ترى التحذيرات داخل حزب
الديمقراطيين بمعنى ان يعني مثلا الان او
منذ قليل سيد احمد طرح فكره ان هناك اسماء
كبيره داخل الحزب الديمقراطي لا ينوي دعم
بايدن الى هذا الترشيح هل تعتقد بان هذا
الجو ملائم لفتح صفحه انتخابات تمهيديه
لالفين
الديمقراطي عنده مشكله داخليه المشكله
الاساسيه انه يعتبرون انا انفسهم بانهم
تقدميين اشتراكيين وهنا رجل يعني كبير في
السن وافكاره يعني لا تتخطى ارائهم بالفعل
بالوضع الراهن ويحاولون بالمجيء بشخصيه
جديده
واصغر سنه
فهو ولكن حزب الديمقراطي يعتبر بانه اذا
ابقوا على على الرئيس بايدن ربما يبقون في
الوسط الامريكي
والمستقلين يصوتون للرئيس بايدن عوض عن اي
منافس له في الحزب الجمهوري وهذا الذي
يحاولون ان يفعلونه ولكن هنالك طبعا اعاده
خلط اوراق في الحزب الديمقراطي لانه الفشل
الاقتصادي بداخل البلاد وتاثيرها على
الشعب العادي يوميا ستلعب دورا اساسيا بعد
سنه ونصف من اليوم وبالفعل يعني ليس هنالك
اي مش لتصحيح هذا الفشل الاقتصادي الذي
نعيشه اليوم في الولايات المتحده سيد احمد
مهما تكون هذه التفاصيل واعتراض البعض على
ترشح بايدن من الديمقراطيين ولكن هل تعتقد
بانه بكل ما في الموضوع من نقاء يقراها
البعض ليس فقط العمر ولكن حتى منهجه
تخلفه عن تحقيق بعض الوعود الانتخابيه
واكثر من نقطه في الواقع اتى عليها
الجمهوريون منتقدين اداره بيض الحاليه
ولكن هل ترى بانه شخص الامثل القادر ان
يخوض غمار الرئاسه عن الحزب الديمقراطي في
هذه المرحله
الحقيقه ان يعني
الديمقراطيين بمختلف تياراتهم يرون ان
الرئيس بايدن حقق افضل ما كان يمكن تحقيقه
من خلال السنوات الماضيه لا يمكن يعني ليس
في الامكان افضل مما كان في رايه
الديمقراطيين يرون ان بايدن مرر اكبر كميه
من المشاريع التشريعيه في التاريخ الحديث
لا يوجد رئيس في التاريخ الحديث مرر نفس
العدد من المشاريع التي مررها بايدن
التضخم في امريكا يرون انهم معقول مقارنه
بما يحدث في بقيه رجال العالم لذلك هم
يعني مصطفون وراء بايدن بايدن اصلا مرشح
الوسط مرشح المعتدلين فبالتالي من يعتقد
انه قد يتمرد عليه هو اليسار او التقدميين
ولكن التقدميين منذ نهايه انتخابات 22 وهم
مستقيم تماما وبقوه وراء بايدن طيب على كل
سيبقى موضوعا المتابعه لنرى كيف ستتم
الامور ونتابع ان كان هناك طبعا اعلان
رسمي عن هذا الترشح حول
سكايب احمد الحمصي البحث في شان الامريكي
ومنورلندو تم حرب رايس وتحالف الامريكان
قوسين الديمقراطيه شكرا لكما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات